welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday doctors are hoping stem-cell
therapy could be a weapon in the fight
against coronavirus on Friday the
company meso blast announced a 300
person trial to determine whether
stem-cell treatments will work in coated
patients suffering from severe lung
inflammation one Hospital in New York
tried it as an experiment with 12
patients ten of whom were able to come
off of a ventilator Adriana Diaz Boake
with one of those survivors and the
doctor leading that steady how do you
feel now though nice call most decision
to order believe you so you're feeling
much better since being released from
the hospital
six-year-old Lewis Naranjo prays every
night / zoom with his relatives back in
Ecuador it's a ritual that family
started while he was hospitalized and
fighting for his life he was unconscious
and on a ventilator for 14 days how were
you feeling ready well of course I can
breathe his daughter Paola took him to
the ER but like so many families struck
by Kovac she couldn't go inside when you
dropped him off at the ER I'm sure
crossed your mind that you might not see
him again
it's one of the biggest guilts that I
have because goodness but you have him
back yes
doctors proposed to treatment used for
other diseases like rheumatoid arthritis
they wanted to give him stem cells from
bone marrow in hopes it would suppress
severe lung inflammation caused by kovat
as he was getting the stem cell infusion
what was going through your mind Mount
Sinai hospitals dr. Karen Osman led the
treatment and is encouraged by the
results in the initial group of 12
patients we saw how do you know that
these patients getting off the
ventilator wouldn't have already gotten
off the ventilator had they not gotten
the stem cells we don't know and we
never dare to claim that it was related
to the cells but it's only with a
randomized control trial that we'll
really be able to make a true comparison
if it turns out once you do the
randomized study that this works well
this either quote-unquote miracle
treatment that we're looking for no no
no the miracle treatment will be a
vaccine with income from their family
jewelry business
cut off the Naranjo's have fallen behind
on rent but lewis is focusing on getting
stronger and gaining back the 25 pounds
he lost at the hospital you said your
wife cooks very well he also credits his
doctors - yes yes yes a thousand thank
yous for his recovery for CBS this
morning Saturday Adriana Diaz and thank
you to all of those medical
professionals doing so much to help so
many